let's now go to George Anthony devolder
Santos George Santos the lying of lying
congressman who was arrested yesterday
on 13 criminal counts held a manic
unhinged press conference after being
arrested it's wacky we're going to look
at it it's just really really wacky
stuff and he is trying to do the Trump
thing where he says it's a Witch Hunt
and it's all unfair and blah blah blah
blah blah he gives this event in Islip
New York vishbura is the guy if you're
watching in the blue checkered suit over
Santos's right shoulder he's
increasingly a corrosive actor in
Republican politics there in Long Island
um let's listen to what Santos had to
say and this is this is crazy I'm
warning you this is Bonkers stuff
beginning of the ability for me to
address and defend myself we have an
indictment we have all we have the
information that the government wants to
come after me on and I'm going to comply
I've been complying throughout this
entire process I have no desire not to
comply at this point they've been
gracious in there now I'm gonna have to
go and fight to defend myself the
reality is is I'm sorry it's a Witch
Hunt because it it makes no sense that
in four months four months five months
I'm indicted you have Joe Biden's entire
family receiving
deposits from nine the crowd not
reacting positively to that nine family
members receiving money from foreign
from foreign destinations into their
bank accounts it's been years of
exposing a lot of you here have reported
on them and yet no investigation is
launched into them I'm gonna fight I
will and I'm just going I'm getting back
to that I'm gonna fight my battle I'm
gonna deliver all right so it's a Witch
Hunt he says asked whether he will
resign he says that he will not
you will not resign Congressman I will
not resign now he may be kicked out one
interesting thing that happened in the
last 24 hours is that Kevin McCarthy the
Republican Speaker of the House said I
do not support the re-election of George
Santos now you might say who cares if
Kevin McCarthy doesn't support it in in
general
Republican leadership supports the
re-election of Republicans who are
running for re-election so this could be
the beginning of Republicans actually
saying uh we've got to
um we've got to do something about this
hilariously he was he George Santos was
asked why did you apply for unemployment
benefits When you were making 120 Grand
a year working and of course this is one
of the different frauds that he's
alleged to have committed and he says
well that this is all going to be part
of my defense in an orderly fashion and
we'll start right here
why would you apply for unemployment
benefits When you had a job making 120
000 a year right by the way I have for
people who are watching there's about 80
of who are not watching there's about 80
microphones in front of him it almost
looks satirical
and there's a guy in the back holding a
sign that says devolder defrauds
devoters which is just a beautiful dish
it's this SNL can't do anything with
this because it wouldn't look any
different to parody this event this is
part of my defense that was an accurate
information and I will get to clear my
name on this during the pandemic it
wasn't very clear I don't understand
where the government's getting their
information but I will presents
prosecutor say that you got over twenty
thousand dollars in unemployment
benefits sir how is that acceptable
ma'am like I said my employment was
changed during the time I don't
understand where the government's coming
from I'll present my defense he's all
totally confused at another moment he
completely delusionally says that in a
couple of years he'll be chairman of a
committee in the house now listen he may
or may not make it out of the next month
I don't know it depends on what
Republicans are going to do the idea
that he's going to get reelected and
subsequently become the chair of a
committee really is a level of delusion
that raises a lot of red flags
well look the way I look at it I'll be a
chairman of a committee in a couple of
years if you just look at the standards
of Congress look at this dining there
you go soon this is no worse than
anything everybody else is doing in the
House and Senate so he'll be chairman of
a committee trying to put sort of a
positive spin on this entire thing he
says he's feeling fine despite 13
criminal charges please
I'm addressing one of your colleagues
here I don't want to give the back of
the county so
as usual Jody I I do my best to be a
positive person life is already as bad
as it gets out there so I I'm fine and
somebody yelling his lips are moving
therefore he must be lying is the
implication
um okay he this is maybe the funniest
moment he starts talking about getting
back to Washington DC to vote on it like
a border Bill he's pretending to be a
normal congressman and there's something
so funny like yes members of Congress
vote on bills but the idea that this guy
is going to now be able to just pretend
to be a normal Congressman with 13
criminal counts against him as a joke
uh what are those consequential votes in
in this Congress which is a border Bill
and I'm very looking forward to being
their devote honor all right he's going
to pretend to be a normal congressman
and then lastly
um Fox News caught up with uh desantos
with Santos's lawyer on the way out the
lawyer was mostly interested in finding
his car but he did say
I don't really have anything to do with
Santos choosing to hold that wacky press
conference you didn't have too much that
you wanted to share at this time he just
talked
to him say about your client is feeling
right now
it's looking for his car but hold on
with us Martha
I mean he had a lot to say in that press
conference that's up to him okay I know
you said you didn't want to try it in
the media but how is he feeling he
looked a little nervous when he was in
court today a lot of serious allegations
how many times have you been arrested
all right so making the point that
people just get nervous when they get
arrested but that it's really up to
Santos whether he holds these press
conferences so a completely manic wacky
event it's taking on a sort of circus
Sideshow feel and it seems as though
Santos can't get away from circus side
shows we're going to see it we'll see if
this guy survives the next month I hope
he doesn't but I don't have a prediction
right now I love my car which is
electric I love my bicycle and I have to
say that the perfect medium in between
is my electric bike by Electric if
you're looking to spend about 800 or so
on an e-bike electric is where you want
to go I've tried e-bikes that cost seven
thousand dollars and electric delivers
the same performance and specs but at a
much more reasonable price point I take
my electric e-bike everywhere these days
I've almost completely ditched my
regular bike for now e-bikes are of
course better for the environment than
taking a car the e-bike gives you more
flexibility and range than a regular
bicycle you can go further you can see
more my e-bike is just my favorite form
of cardio at this point it comes fully
assembled to your door it includes a
bright LCD display seven speed gearing
five levels of pedal assist and a
powerful battery that's removable so you
can bring it indoors for charging it's
also fully foldable so I can put it in
the back of my car and they have
financing for as little as 73 bucks a
month go to electricebikes.com to learn
more explore all of the incredible
e-bike models they offer the link is
down below